so it was a sunday and the president was
feeling better and so he decided it was
time for a drive so he released another
video in which he said guys
you know what i'm missing all y'all and
sure i have
a window right here and i could just
like go there and open it up and just
wave to everybody like ronald reagan
after he got shot in 1980
but instead i need to drive around in a
car
he's going riding in his automobile okay
so here was the video of president trump
riding around in his car
there he is waving he's wearing a mask
inside the car and you have a bunch of
trump supporters
outside cheering okay everybody in the
media went holy crazy about this and you
knew they would right you knew they
would which is why
was this like a wonderful idea on its
face no i mean if you're sick
the way you are supposed to be sick with
kovid is you're supposed to quarantine
quarantining means you're not supposed
to do stuff like this right now
again jennifer rubin who five minutes
before was like why didn't you take a
car to the hospital now she's like why
is he even in a car at all
he should get back on marine one okay
but the rest of the media
again decided to go absolutely bananas
over this thing now again two
for the thousandth time two things can
be short ones is it a good idea
to get in a vehicle and drive around in
the vehicle while you have coved
the general answer is no it is not a
good idea to do this right we all made
fun of chris cuomo
when he had covid and then he decided to
jet set out
to his second property and check the
place out while he had covet
but is it also true that the president
is likely working with medical
professionals when he decides to do this
of course that's true but it doesn't
matter our
our twitter medical professionals decide
to go absolutely nuts about this so dr
james
phillips md who's the chief of disaster
medicine in george washington universal
uh university emergency medicine and he
is the walter he's an attending at
walter reed which doesn't mean he's
trump's attending it just means he's
attending at walter reed walter is a
very large hospital there are many
attendings so it wouldn't be too hard to
find some doctor
who presumably doesn't like trump very
much he tweeted out
every single person in the vehicle
during that completely unnecessary
presidential drive by
just now has to be quarantined for 14
days they might get sick they may die
for political
theater commanded by trump to put their
lives at risk
for theater this is insanity
okay and then you had dr leanna wen
who's the contributing columnist
for the washington post and cnn medical
analyst
i believe former head of planned
parenthood correct uh so d liana wen
who again has her own political priors
she tweeted out if donald trump were my
patient in unstable condition
and contagious illness and he suddenly
left the hospital to go for a car ride
that endangers himself and others
i'd call security to restrain him then
perform a psychiatric evaluation to
examine his decision-making capacity
well then you're probably not like a
very good doctor because it turns out
that the walter reed physicians cleared
him to do this according to catherine
herridge
over at cbs doctors okay the president's
drive by supporters deputy press
secretary tells mark knoller appropriate
precautions were taken
in the execution of this movement to
protect the president and all those
supporting it including
personal protective equipment cleared by
the medical team as safe to do so
apparently the secret service agents
were not just wearing masks along with
trump they were also wearing goggles
they were also wearing
like full-on gowns basically they were
they're wearing whatever personal
protective equipment
they needed in order to be safe
and for all of the members of the media
who were fulminating look at secret
service secret service being put at risk
it's so terrible see again
this is a good idea by trump no it is
not actually but
with that said secret service you guys
are very very worried about the secret
service today let me just point out that
over the weekend
there are a bunch of black lives matter
protesters protesting and they're doing
it at the white house which means the
secret service is right there
and there are videos and photos of
people shouting directly in their faces
people screaming
directly in their faces and you guys
didn't have one word to say about the
safety and security of the secret
service agents
because apparently that's deeply
necessary it's very necessary to have
people scream without masks directly in
the face
of secret service agents because at
least they are screaming for a racial
justice or whatever
cause of the day is and so forgive me my
skepticism about your motives
media when you talk about how how deeply
you care about the protection of our
secret service agents
okay then my favorite thing the white
house correspondents association
they couldn't even get the message
straight so was it bad for trump to go
on the
drive or is it bad that he didn't invite
the press to also go along
with the drive according to the hill the
white house correspondents association
on sunday blasted president trump's
brief
foray out of his hospital room to wave
to supporters from an suv calling it
outrageous
and criticizing the lack of transparency
around the photo op
white house correspondents association
president zeke miller said in a
statement
it is outrageous for the president to
have left the hospital even briefly amid
a health crisis
without a protective pool present to
ensure the american people know
where their president is and how he is
doing now more than ever the american
public deserves independent coverage of
the president so they can be reliably
informed about his health so it's
terrible terrible terrible
that trump would go outside also he was
endangering everybody also why didn't we
have reporters in the car with him
so that's solid stuff right there that's
okay so what exactly
is trump's health condition as of right
now
apparently he's okay people are trying
to blow it out of proportion that he's
taking a steroid
okay lots of people take steroids i mean
seriously like steroids are a very very
common
commonly used medication they are safe
for use in children as designated by the
fda
the use of a of a clinical steroid in
order to
presumably help tamp down covid or or
work on the immune system so to tamp
down covert
that is not like the end of the world
however
there was confusion about his condition
over
the weekend we'll get to that we'll get
to that confusion in just a moment first
it now looks
as though pretty much everybody around
trump has been infected
with covid so trump's campaign manager
bell steppi bill stephen
he tested positive for coven attorney
general william barr has not tested
positive for covey but he's going to
self quarantine anyway
just in case for the next few days we
also have
chris christie being diagnosed and
christie obviously
is also in a high risk bracket
considering that he is obviously
heavily overweight we we have a bunch of
people who are
at the cleveland clinic debate who
apparently got tested
and um and came out positive so
this has turned into its own little
super spreader core
which is why again should the president
have been downplaying
the way that he the way that he did
masking right just in his attitude not
even in so far as what he says but his
attitude
no should there have been at this white
house rose garden ceremony people who
are hugging each other and all up on
each other even if they had already been
tested
probably not right none of this was kind
of cdc standard
i get it i get the narrative i do and
again
two things can be true at once for the
fifth time two things can be short ones
botched by the white house media's bad
at this i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the ben shapiro show if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content